you
well a pheasant is a bird and they need
to be plucked
after being slaughtered
our trucks and you probably don't think
much of me just a lonely pheasant
plucker
wasn't just listening
pheasant plucker and nobody's ever
the pleasant mother pheasant plucker
Faysal documentation
and the days were hard and the nights
were long so to keep their spirits I may
say this
mother pheasant plucker
music as like
blessing pheasant plucker and nobody's
ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant
mother pheasant plucker
and she loved to put the mother
pheasants yes I could tell and she sang
this song as she plucked all day long
she never ever ever got the leer
another dozen news
just as the new music
wasn't pheasant plucker and nobody's
ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant
disguise it just
as I pluck mother pheasants
pleasant pheasant plucker and nobody's
ever heard a buzzin
let me see the up
pleasant pheasant plucker and nobody's
ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant
plucker
nobody's ever heard of
there nobody's ever heard of
thanks to schmucky and weevils for
making that music video for me I lost my
wife we've been playing that song on
tour it's been going poorly the points
we're headed now to a friend of ours a
house tour has been amazing it's going
well yeah it's great thank you so much
to all the people who have come out to
spend time with Hank reading the perfect
strangers and harrying the bottles and
ripples Pony Club and Andrew Huang and
Rob Scallon I'm not sharing a ton of
behind-the-scenes stuff from the tour on
this video or any videos because I'm
putting it all into the podcast because
awesome which is a behind-the-scenes
tour diary of the tour because awesome
if you like podcasts that are like 20 to
30 minutes a piece and it's just what
life is like on tour for a nerd band
final bit of news the bad people shirts
are only going to be on sale for another
like 12 or 24 hours or so so if you want
to get one of those this is your last
chance and I have arrived at my friend's
house my friend Barack Obama I think's
again just working and people there's
links in description for them and thank
everyone who's come out to see us on
tour it's been a really fantastic time
I've had a great time feels like a lot
of the other people have as well thanks
John I'll see you on Tuesday last time I
was here I was in it it's weird